We had to take this first time ever TV live performance...
...at this stage, AMAs.
We were like, too excited and nervous at the time...
...and it's been a long and amazing ride since then,...
...but nobody could have ever bet on the odds of us standing here receiving this award.
Except, except y'all Army, except y'all.
Seven boys from Korea, united by a love for music...
...met the love and support from all the armies all over the world.
This whole thing is a miracle.
Seriously, we'll never take this for granted.
Thank you so much.
We love you all.
We want to give this honor to you guys.
We just wanted to make people happy with our music.
We believe that this award opens the beginning of our new chapter.
In the past few years, we learned that each and every moment is precious.